i've done that work with guys where
they'll like put you in handcuffs or
something but they're not real and
you're just like that's act that's free
acting class but
you should be saying thank you you were
just saved i don't know how much insert
price of acting
pretending to be tied up is
like one giant kegel for your body it
also takes it's so much work it's like
10 times
who am i i'm never i've never had
anything introduced in the bedroom like
that am i just a loser no
like no you
say it
no
based on the way you just confronted me
about that i can only imagine what you
would do if somebody even tried to
introduce a prop in the bedroom
yeah exactly show me that is literally
bring it out you don't see it because
you're the dom yeah
you have to do
it say it
say you love my pussy
say it
that's a really good impression
that's not your friend you are a dom
you're just editing
me while
oh my god oh my god she has one of those
like laptop tables from l.l bean teen
he's like please for the love of god
turn off whitney's voice
actually he might like it better he's
eating my pussy hollywood baby
baby
okay just checking thank you needed to
get a really never had a guy try to do
something dominant choke you you're
blonde see blondes they don't do that
too nothing i've never had anyone do
anything it's a blonde thing i couldn't
tell you when the last time somebody
didn't try to choke me off what
give me the logistics are you her topper
was it after you were ordering at a
restaurant
yes yep no every time i go out to eat
every time i'm fine
god we but here's my question in what
position like when does it is it
introduced like
do they want you i don't get it it just
it
it doesn't matter wait the the choking
the joking it doesn't matter like what
what happened when you tried to
girl boss
oh yes
yes yes
this is literally the most psycho shit
is it uh yes grace tried to equal out
the pain i will maybe
i just feel like maybe you have to stop
listening to beyonce or i don't know
something needs a habit where no it's my
friends it's all my questions quality i
understand in a lot of ways
but this is where it's just drawing the
line yes uh i'm a feminist um
and
are we but we're the good kind
the kind that knows their
place well i've been talking a lot to my
friends about how like guys will just do
stuff to us in bed without really like
asking and it's usually pretty like
innocuous but we want them to ask like
kind of guys can i touch your face hey
grace
um but like
i don't know we're like what would
happen if we like tried so i was if you
okay i i was hooking up with this guy
for the first time and we were both for
the first time i think you were also
standing up we were so drunk no we were
not standing up okay okay um we were so
drunk i was on top of him and i was like
what would happen if i just like tried
to choke him a little bit
by the way this is how women get
murdered yeah that's true i know
i was also like at a house i'd never
been bitch
oh this is someone else's hole
literally
is the only person that can do it so
wait did you use two hands or no one
hand and it wasn't even i didn't i was
he just gave me a look like
like i've never seen somebody look so
like confused and like taken aback at
the same time and i was like i'm so
sorry
are you telling me that your friend your
roommates and friends tell you you
should do this right no no we just like
talk about it well my friend one of my
friends um she a guy slapped her in bed
without like like it wasn't on the table
on the face
not like a spanking he slapped her
across the face so she was like
she
stop pretending you don't know the
difference if it's if you have a no i'm
full i'm fully on board with that and
aware of that and i agree with that yeah
but this was like
she was just like
i was so surprised that he did that like
it didn't hurt it wasn't like i wasn't
whatever but that's part of it she was
so surprised that he did that so she was
just like i just slapped him back i
didn't know what to do
okay and he was like you slapped me and
she was like you slapped me first oh my
god
women are broken we got broken when did
this happen who what who did did oprah
do this who did this right oh my god who
did this anyone slapped me that i gave
the privilege
of fucking me imagine i would call the
police
immediately followed by their mother
[Music]
four four four five
[Applause]